nice to see you man nice to see you um
listen i just want to say that this is a
real thrill for me i'm a huge fan of the
matrix films and getting to talk to you
guys is amazing
i know you've been asked a lot of
questions and i'm gonna hopefully ask
something no one has asked which is i
laughed so loud when i saw chad playing
uh uh your husband
chad
right handsome chad i
i couldn't believe i was when i i just
laughed my ass off and most people won't
realize who chad is uh but it's full
circle because he worked on the first
one um and i'm not gonna get to talk to
lana so how did chad end up playing
handsome chad and getting to be in the
film
um yeah i mean i think that they have a
real affection for each other and i know
that
you know chad always describes going to
wachowski film school chad was my stunt
double on the trilogy
and um
and
uh i think that
lana the director and writer appreciates
chad and his film making
and there was a lot that lana was trying
to interweave in terms of life and art
for all of the people in the film
and artists in the film and
i think for her it gave her a chuckle
that
chad was the husband
to
trinity's
count uh
matrix counterpart
right uh i i had a blast with it um for
both of you i am curious you guys have
done
so many tough scenes to film in these
movies um and for for each of you which
sequence or scene
ended up being the one when you were
filming it you're like get the f out of
here how are we actually going to do
this and i am totally nervous to film
i i think i mean i think the leap is
probably
you know what came to mind was the goo
oh the girl you know like because
we're up there and we knew it was going
to be hard the the jumping off the
building but but we were so ready and it
was so like yeah but the goo was
the pod so we're talking about the pods
that uh the trinity and neo live in in
the machine world so there's these tubs
full of goo
that we try to get the temperature right
but you're in it for eight hours a day
with tubes and things and being sealed
yeah
yeah i mean we do it because we're there
we're professional we want to tell the
whole story but that was
challenging it's uncomfortable yeah
it's very yeah it's not as sexy and fun
as leaping off a building yeah lying in
goo for eight hours submerged
yeah yeah my last question for you guys
um trinity means so much to so many
people uh and i'm just curious when did
you each realize uh the important what
trinity means to so many people
yeah i mean you can speak to that i know
i mean
when did you first realize that i mean i
saw it as soon as
i met carrie ann but uh and the role
uh
and uh
yeah and i think i think the rochowskis
i feel the rochowskis love trinity and i
think they might love trinity the most
and i think
i think we see that we feel that you
know with her introduction in the film
with her fierceness with her strength
uh with her wisdom and with her love in
her heart
and you know i i hear all the time just
how much
trinity changed a lot of women's and a
lot of people's perspective in life like
a kind of champion and inspiration for
them
yeah i feel like i i can't quite feel
the question some for some reason um
it's not that i
i intellectually i guess
can remember people talking to me that
way but it doesn't feel
like when i hear it when somebody says
to me that like it through the press
junket i'm i'm moved by it but i i can't
say that i
that i know that
if that makes sense yeah
because you're trinity
i completely got it listen i got to stop
uh i just want to say congrats on the
new movie and thank you so much for
giving me your time
thanks thank you